in this video I'm going to show you how
to build a large language model app to
chat with your own data this is arguably
the cheapest and the most efficient way
to get started with llms for your own
business but before we do that I want to
back up a little the technique that
makes this work is called retrieval
augmented generation a fancy way of
saying we Chuck in chunks of your data
into a prompt and get the llm to answer
based on that context the first thing
that we need to do is build an app to
chat to there's a bunch of dependencies
that I need to import they're mainly
from Lang chain but there's a little
streamlit and what's the next to earing
for good measure I'll explain these as I
use them so don't stress for now
streamlit has a great set of track comp
component so I'm going to make the most
of them add in a chat input component to
hold the prompt and then display the
user message using the chat message
component via markdown this means I can
now see the messages showing up in the
app but it's only displaying the last
message posted not all of them easy fix
create a streamlet state variable I'll
call it message and append all of the
user prompts into it while add it I'll
save the rooll type in this case user
into the dictionary and then I can test
it out hm but the history doesn't show
up Well turns out I haven't printed out
the historical messages yet Loop through
all the messages in the session State
message variable and use the chat
message component to display them and
wait did I save the app of course not i'
never make a mistake like that let's
just try that again and look at this
historical prompts that have been passed
through whoopy Doo Nick where's the llm
at well let's do it I'm going to use the
Lang chain interface to whaton next. a
why well it uses state-of thee out large
language models doesn't use your data to
train and it's built for business but
that's just scraping the surface to do
that I'll create a credentials
dictionary with an API and use the ml
service URL you can create an API key
from the IBM Cloud am menu URLs for
different regions are shown on the
screen right now then the llm I'm using
llama 270b chat because I'm pretty fond
of those furry buggers pass through some
decoding parameters and specify the
project ID from what's next now send the
pum through to the llm and boom wait it
looks like it's running but I need to
show the llm responses as well easy
enough with the streamlit chat message
component note the chat role for the llm
response is assistant rather than user
this help helps to differentiate the
responses I'll render The Prompt as
markdown and save the message to the
session State as well that way the
history is displayed in the app and now
it works yeah yeah that's great but
where's the custom data come into play
entering phase three I'll add in a load
PDF function and specify the name of the
PDF here then pass that to the Lang
chain Vector store index Creator and
choose the embeddings function to use
this basically chunks up the PDF and
loads it into a vector database chrom
ofb in this case wrapping it in the st.
Cas resource function means that
streamlet doesn't need to reload it each
time which makes it a whole heat faster
anyway I can then pass that index to the
Lang chain retriever QA chain and swap
out the base llm for the Q&A chain using
chain. run and we can now chat with our
PDF in this case a PDF to do with
generative AI meta I
know